writer will kirsten
thank you mr speaker on the 11th of may
the prime minister said that the
government's covid strategy
and i quote him will be governed
entirely by the science
on the 21st of september the
government's own scientific advisors
sage gave very clear advice
they said a package of interventions
including a circuit breaker
will be needed to prevent an exponential
rise in cases
why did the prime minister reject that
advice
and abandon the science
prime minister mr speaker uh we will do
whatever it takes to
fight this virus and and to defeat it
uh but since he quotes the sage advice i
might just remind him that on page one
it says
that all the interventions considered uh
have associated costs in terms of
health and well-being and that policy
makers will need to
consider analysis of economic impacts
and the associated harms
alongside this epidemiological
assessment and the advice that i have uh
today mr speaker
is that if we do the regional approach
that commended itself
to the house and indeed to the right
honorable gentleman
on monday uh mr speaker we can
bring down the r and we can bring down
the virus so
will he stick to his position of monday
and support that approach
yeah here's starman i don't think that
approach goes far enough
i need neither to sage and the prime
minister
the prime minister talks of the
costs since he rejected sage's advice on
the 21st of september i remind him
the r rate has gone up the infection
rate is quadrupled
hospital admissions have gone from 275 a
day to 628 a day in england
yesterday 441 coveted patients were on
ventilators
and the number of deaths recorded was
tragically
the highest since june the 10th that's
the cost of rejecting
the advice sage has a clear view on why
that's happening
what's the prime minister's view on why
these numbers are all heading
in the wrong direction mr speaker i set
that out very clearly in the house on on
monday and uh the difference between uh
this stage of the the pandemic and march
and eight pullers
uh as the house knows very well is that
the
disease is appearing much more strongly
in some parts of the country
than in others and in liverpool for
instance alas
the figures are now running at 670 cases
per 100 000
against 33 cases per 100 000
in cornwall 540 cases per 100 000
in newcastle alas against 32 in
north norfolk and that is why the tiered
approach the three-tiered approach
that we set out on monday and that he
then
supported is the right way forward and
uh we want
to put in the most stringent measures
necessary in the places where the virus
is surging in order to get it down where
it is surging mr speaker that is the
that is the logical thing to do uh so
will he get on to
uh his labor friends in those parts of
the north of england where
we want to work with them to put those
very stringent measures in place
in order to deliver the reductions that
the whole country
wants to see will he support those
measures because he wouldn't support
them last night mr speaker yes
mr speaker i think the prime minister's
behind the curve again
he probably hasn't noticed that this
morning the council leaders in greater
manchester that he's just quoted
including the mayor and including the
conservative leader of bolton council
have said in a press statement that they
support a circuit break
above tier three restrictions keep up
prime minister
the big problem the big problem the
prime minister has
and it's from the sage minutes that make
it absolutely clear that his two main
policies
track and trace and local restrictions
simply haven't worked
and we can't stand by in june the prime
minister told me that track and trace
will play a vital part in ensuring that
we do not have a second spike this
winter his words
three months later sage have concluded
that track and trace their words
is only having a marginal impact on
transmission
they go on to say and this is the really
worrying part
that this is likely to further decline
in the future
further decline so let's not have the
usual nonsense
that anyone asking the prime minister a
question about track and tracy somehow
knocking the nhs
this is sage's assessment the
government's own advisors
so after 12 billion pounds let's have a
straight answer
why does the prime minister think that
his track and trace system
has gone so wrong mr speaker it's his
thanks to nhs test and trace
uh that is now testing more people than
any other country in europe
that we know that we know where the
disease
is surging and it's we know uh that it
is regionally distributed rather than
nationally
distributed at the moment and that gives
us a chance now
to do the right thing he wants to close
pubs he wants to close bars he wants to
close businesses
in areas across the country where the
incidence is low and he wants to that's
what he wants to do
and he wants to do it now and yet he and
yet he voted to do
nothing last night nothing in the areas
where the incident is highest mr speaker
he says one thing at five o'clock about
calling for a national
lockdown when it came to a vote in this
house of commons mr speaker
to impose more stringent measures he
failed even
to turn up mr speaker
i know that for someone who's been an
opportunist all his life
this is difficult this is difficult to
understand
but having read and considered the sage
advice
i have genuinely concluded that a
circuit break
is in the national interest genuinely
concluded
mr speaker it's the failure of the prime
minister's strategy
that means tougher measures are now
unavoidable
that's sage's view sage has advised
that a circuit breaker should act to
reduce
r below one should reset the incidence
of disease to a lower level
and should set the epidemic back by
approximately 28 days or more
all three are vital and that's why
labour backs it
so can the prime minister tell us what
is his alternative plan
to get our below one are below one
prime minister mr speaker the plan is
the plan that the right honourable
gentleman
uh supported on monday and and the
the whole point mr speaker is to seize
this moment now
to avoid the misery of another national
lockdown into which he wants to go uh
headlong
by delivering a regional solution and
mr speaker opportunism is i'm afraid the
name of the game for the party uh
opposite because
uh they they backed they backed the rule
of six or he backed the rule of six
and then refused to vote for it uh uh
i think at three o'clock mr speaker the
shadow health spokesman said that a
national
lockdown would be disastrous at five
o'clock
he was calling for it uh mr speaker
let's
let's let's go back to the approach that
he was supporting
on uh on monday let's try to avoid the
misery
of another national lockdown which he
would want to impose
as i say in a in a headlong way and
let's work
together let's work together as as he
was prepared to do all money to keep
kids in school
who he will now yank out a yank out of
school in a peremptory
way keep our economy going and
keep jobs and livelihoods supported in
this country
mr speaker and let's take the common
sensical regional approach and will he
kindly
uh spell out to all his colleagues
across the whole of the country that
that is the best way forward as indeed
he did on monday here's tom mr speaker
following the advice is now uh
apparently opportunistic presumably
he'll say the same to the leader of
bolton council conservative leader who
this morning said he supports a circuit
break
mr speaker mr speaker i've just listened
to what the prime minister said
about his strategy to get our below one
but i can't think of a single scientist
who backs him
he will know that the chief medical
officer said on monday
that he his words chief medical officer
not
confident nor is anyone confident
that the tier three proposals for the
highest rate would be enough
that's tier three that's tier three
the highest tier so why is the prime
minister
so confident that his approach will get
the r8 below one so confident
or is that no longer the government plan
i'm afraid mr speaker he is
misrepresenting the position
doubtless diligent doubtless
inadvertently what
what our advice is that if the regional
measures are tier three
all at all levels were implemented in
full
uh with the support and the active uh
cooperation of local
leaders as indeed we have seen from the
uh the leader of the liverpool
city region i i pay tribute to him like
i thank him for
for what he is doing if we saw full and
proper enforcement
uh if uh they were able to conduct
proper local tests and trace with the
support of the 500 million pounds that
we're giving
then yes those measures those measures
would deliver mr speaker the reduction
in the r
locally regionally that we need in order
to avert
what none of us want to see what none of
us want to see except
now the right honourable gentleman
having performed this extraordinary
u-turn
none of us want to see and that is the
disaster the disaster the words
of the shadow health spokesman of a
national lockdown we don't want to go
there we want the regional approach he
should cooperate with it
[Applause]
mr speaker i've supported the government
and all their measures so far
and i and i've taken and i've taken
criticism of it
but i think this measure is wrong and a
circuit breaker is in the national
interest
i've read the advice of sage and the
government has rejected it
mr speaker this is my last question and
i'm sure the prime minister
i'm sure the prime minister is
pre-prepared rant ready as usual
but we're at a tipping point time is
running out
maybe we can seize the moment and ask
answer a question
this morning the telegraph quotes senior
government sources
saying the chances of the prime minister
backing a circuit break in the next two
weeks
are about 80 percent is that right
and if it is why doesn't he do it now
save lives fix testing and protect the
nhs
mr speaker this is a a railroad who
claims to be
supporting the government one day and
then performs a dramatic
u-turn the next everybody
mr speaker he continues to support the
rule of six one day then
uh pulls his support the next uh he
wants tough measures and then refuses to
to vote for them everybody mr speaker
can see
what he's doing labor have said it
themselves
they see this mr speaker as a good
crisis for the labour party
and one uh they wish to exploit uh we
see this
as a national crisis that we are going
to turn around
and the way we're going to do it mr
speaker the way we're going to do it and
i i
i rule out nothing of course in in
combating
the virus but we are going to do it with
the local the regional
approach that can drive down and will
drive
down the virus if it is properly
implemented
and that is what i believe he should be
supporting he said he
said he'd support it on monday mr
speaker this is our opportunity
to keep things going to keep our kids in
school
to keep our businesses going that i
think is what the people of this country
want to do this is our opportunity to do
that and
to suppress the virus where it is
surging
he refuses to accept that approach today
i hope that not for the first time mr
speaker
he will change his mind and think the
better of his actions
mr speaker one of the great unsung
achievements of the coalition government
was the recruitment of 4200
extra health visitors now as an
experienced father himself